on a bien compris détruire les gestion
et l'organisation d'albanie bulgarie
milieu de tout ça on est assez d'accord
tous mes sens le situer française que
vous dites vouloir défendre la voyelle
sont jamais allés manifester cette
semaine devant le sénat c'est pas des
tchétchènes
mais sans doute parce qu'elles ont mal
compris les choses c'est pas compliqué
en voilà une voix si clair car tenez
bon chemin à faire car tenez donc vous
êtes porte-parole d'une association qui
s'appelle cabiria et vous faisiez partie
donc de cette grosse manif devant le
sénat mardi dernier il faut rappeler
quand même que c'est la première fois
que les prostituées manifestent en
france depuis 1975
on va pas faire un débat de trois heures
j'ai simplement posé le problème
clairement on al'impression je vous dis
franchement l'impression quand on
regarde ce que vous faites avec sarkozy
que vous traiter le problème de la
prostitution uniquement comme une
nuisance pour les voisins
c'est à dire que le problème en fait
pour vous servir d'être je dis pas que
c'est un problème d'ailleurs mais ça a
l'air d'être des prostituées qui
pratiquent leur art dans les cours
d'immeubles les préservatifs sur
lesquels on peut glisser le matin en
sortant de chez soi je dis pas que c'est
pas un problème je dis qu'on a
l'impression que c'est comme ça que vous
le voyez en tous les cas alors c'est
règle pas le problème de la prostitution
en général parce que si elles sont pas
sur le trottoir et si elles sont pas
dans des maisons closes puisque les
maisons closes ont été fermées en france
par marc trichard en 1945 où vous voulez
les m nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui
à des dangers importants
j'en ai parlé la prostitution étrangères
oui le trafic de drogue
vous savez très bien que les proxénètes
je connais crise le problème n'est pas
que les proxénètes les proxénètes qui
exploite les réseaux de prostitution
étrangères bien souvent ne sont même pas
sûrs d'avoir projet de loi y a pas un
texte contre les proxénètes vous vous
attaquer aux plus faibles
les prostituées étrangères que vous
renvoyer dans leur pays les prostituées
françaises que vous mettez en prison
nous nous donnons les moyens en les
interpellant de leur proposer soit
d'être raccompagné à la frontière et de
se voir retirer leur titre de séjour
soit de se voir donner un titre de
séjour de longue durée à porter du
moment où elle nous donnerait l'origine
de leur filière et le nom de longs
échanges mais la première fois en droit
mans c'est qu'on aiderait à droit à
quelqu'un qui dénonce des ratios gosses
la première fois au monde en droit
contre délation et s'agit de détruire
des réseaux de proxénètes l'année
son nom est simple les françaises
maintenant elles ont pas le droit d'être
contre toi l ont pas droit dans des
maisons closes puisqu'en france n a plus
qu est ce que vous en faites
est ce que vous pensez sérieusement que
sarkozy et vous vous avez éradiquer la
prostitution dans ce pays ça existe
depuis des millénaires a coûté j'avais
le sentiment de vous avoir dit à
plusieurs reprises que tel n'était pas
notre intention
nous savons bien que c'est le plus vieux
métier du monde et nous n'avons pas la
volonté de le remettre en cause
ça fait partie de l'histoire du monde
maintenant alors est ce que répondait
nous est ce que votre idée derrière tout
ça sa saison